[Musik]
ostersegen 2020 papst franziskus spendet
den segen urbi et orbi im fast
menschenleeren petersdom familienfest
auf distanz wie feiern die deutschen
ostern in zeiten der kontaktsperre und
krankenhäuser vor dem kollaps in
russland verschärft sich die lage rapide
immer mehr menschen infizieren sich mit
dem vormonat aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein ostersonntag wie wir
ihn noch nie erlebt haben guten abend
schön dass sie dabei sind
ostern zu corona zeiten das ist offenbar
noch mehr als sonst das fest der
hoffnung diese krise könnte zum
glücksfall der geschichte werden sagt
der vorsitzende der katholischen
bischofskonferenz georg bätzing und
meint dass die welt danach eine
solidarischere und achtsamer sein könnte
ostern in virus zeiten das heißt aber
auch leere kirchen überall auf der welt
strenge auflagen im heiligen land die
grabeskirche in jerusalem ist für
gläubige gesperrt und dann der vatikan
still und völlig verlassen der
petersplatz wo der papst sonst vor
zehntausenden den segen spendet aus rom
andreas postel das kroner virus im jahr
2020 verändert fast alles die
osterbotschaft nicht jesus christus ist
auferstanden papst franziskus verkündet
die frohe botschaft in der heiligen
ostermesse diesmal im fast
menschenleeren petersdom wie der pest
noch kriege haben in rom jemals
gemeinsame feiern zum höchsten fest der
christen verhindern können der papst
wendet sich in diesem jahr ganz
besonders an die weltweit von corona
virus betroffenen an die armen und
schwachen die helfer in der not und
bietet für die verstorbenen
er richtet sich auch speziell an europa
und erinnert an den geist der
solidarität nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
die europäische union steht heute vor
einer epochalen herausforderung von der
nicht nur ihre zukunft sondern die der
ganzen welt abhängt lasst uns nicht die
gelegenheit versäumen einen weiteren
beweis der solidarität zu erbringen
auch wenn wir dazu neue wege einschlagen
müssen erneut kritisiert der pontifex
gleichgültigkeit egoismus spaltung und
krieg es brauche brot statt waffen in
der welt
auf dem petersplatz fehlen in diesem
jahr die zehntausende pilger aus aller
welt per livestream übertragen spendet
pubs franziskus im anschluss
traditionell den segen urbi et orbi der
stadt und dem erdkreis
das sei für viele ein einsames fest auch
darauf hat der papst hingewiesen
eigentlich wäre ja gerade jetzt für
gläubige trost und nähe in den
gottesdiensten so wichtig geht aber
nicht wegen des virus
die kirchenvertreter versuchen das beste
daraus zu machen zeigt annette fischer
es ist eine merkwürdige osterzeit für
ingrid wittke normalerweise würde sie in
ihren gemeinden um teuchern jeden tag
einen gottesdienst feiern
stattdessen verteilt sie selbst
geschriebene andachten im digitalen netz
gibt es viel an alternativ angebotenen
die schon bereitgestellt werden aber was
ist mit den ganzen menschen die wenig
aufs internet zugreifen oder gar nicht
und haben angefangen gleich in der
ersten woche haus andachten zu schreiben
seit wochen hat auch sittel böhme wenig
sozialen kontakt daher ist sie dankbar
für diesen service der ordinierten
gemeindepädagogin das gibt schon trost
weil man sich da nicht allein führt und
auch vieles angst genommen wird rundum
teuchern wie überhaupt in sachsen-anhalt
bekennen sich nur wenige zum glauben
doch jetzt in zeiten von corona suchen
immer mehr menschen rat bei ingrid geld
pro tag rufen so viele an wie sonst
nicht in einer woche das interesse nimmt
in den zeiten grundsätzlich zu oder der
wunsch danach jemanden zu finden der am
antworten gibt da wird sicherlich nicht
nur nach kirche gesucht aber da ist
kirche eine institution weil ich selber
merke ich komme eine grenze wo ich mir
selber keine antworten mehr geben kann
antworten geben für die menschen da sein
das geht oft nur noch aus der ferne
selbst beim großen oster
sonntagsgottesdienst landesbischof
friedrich kramer spricht vor ihrem haus
das hat der magdeburger dom in seiner
langen geschichte so noch nicht erlebt
und erst recht nicht dass der
gottesdienst vorab aufgezeichnet und
heute morgen im offenen kanal
ausgestrahlt und im internet gestreamt
wurde
dennoch ist für den christlichen glauben
ja so dass wir uns verbunden wissen wir
nie allein wir wissen dass gott und
christus bei uns ist und es kann graphen
einsamkeit und verzweiflung großer trost
sein und die neuen medien sind die
chance auch sich mit anderen menschen zu
verbinden
das internet ist ebenso eine chance für
die kirche findet ingrid gelte nicht nur
jetzt in der korona krise sondern auch
in zukunft neue wege gehen um wieder
mehr menschen zu erreichen
was macht man an einem solchen
ostersonntag wenn so vieles nicht geht
was sonst so selbstverständlich
dazugehört familienbesuche gemeinsames
essen und feiern ausflüge mit freunden
eine stadtfeld hat sich umgeschaut
die fischerboote abgeschlossen die
ausflugsdampfer an land und auch auf der
promenade in warnemünde ist nur wenig
los osterstimmung will nicht so richtig
aufkommen für mich schwierig ich habe im
unternehmen das geschlossen werden
musste und das doch keine soforthilfe da
also sehr sehr schwierig sich so zu
motivieren wirklich oder fröhlich zu
sein trifft sich ja sonst immer mit der
familie das ist natürlich ein bisschen
traurig jetzt aber man muss das beste
draus machen
das versuchen auch angehörige und
bewohner im seniorenheim in schwerin
trotz besuchs war woods haben viele
verwandte geschenke vorbei gebracht wie
ann sophie grünert früher hat sie ostern
mit ihrer oma groß gefeiert jetzt heißt
es abstand halten
an der isar in münchen nutzen
spaziergänger das schöne wetter um fit
zu bleiben trotzdem vermissen viele ihre
familien wir kommen aber gerade aus der
kirche und haben und kerzen für unsere
familie angezündet und hoffen dass es
einfach die nächsten tage mit der aus
später wieder besser wird dass man auch
mal die familien besuchen können hier
schmelzen die schoko ostereier in der
sonne alles geschlossenen timmendorf die
anwohner aber genießen in diesem jahr
die ruhe und das wunderbar ist natürlich
für die geschäftsinhaber hier ein
problem vielleicht sogar ein
existenzielles für einige und deshalb
ist natürlich nicht wunderbar aber so
vom feeling her dass man das hier mal
für sicherheit als eingeborener
sozusagen ist es auch geschlecht
spazieren gehen und ein wenig seeluft
schnuppern
für einige dann doch ein kleines oster
erlebnis susanne gelhard ist am
rheinufer in mainz und den ganzen tag
mit einer polizei streife unterwegs und
seine wie war das
ja wir waren mit der polizei streife
unterwegs in parks hier am rheinufer in
der innenstadt und auch in wohngebieten
und man muss sagen die polizei hatte
nicht viel zu tun
nachdem am letzten wochenende wesentlich
mehr los war wurden an diesem
osterwochenende bisher kaum verstöße
festgestellt und auch dort wo viel
betrieb war haben sich die meisten an
die regeln gehalten nämlich eineinhalb
meter abstand nicht mehr als zwei
personen zusammen ausgenommen häusliche
gemeinschaften und man muss sagen auch
hier am rhein ist es bisher noch ruhig
und man kann nur hoffen dass es so
weiter geht und viele zeigten sogar
verständnis für die korona
beschränkungen
denn deren einhaltung hängt nicht nur
von kontrollen ab sondern auch von der
einsicht der menschen die eindrücke aus
mainz am rhein dankeschön susanne
gelhard und auch heute gibt es neue
infektionszahlen stand 18 uhr 30 sind
laut johns hopkins universität in
deutschland mehr als 125.000 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt und 3000 mehr als
gestern um diese zeit davon sind
inzwischen mehr als 57.000 menschen
genesen 2907 starben
die ausbreitung verlangsamt sich immer
weiter anfang märz hatte sich die zahl
der erkrankten noch alle zwei tage
verdoppelt nun erst alle 18,3 tage
die verdopplung zeit ist ein kriterium
dafür ob die bundesregierung die
beschränkungen lockert und dann immer
wieder die frage wann und vor allem wie
könnte der weg zurück zur normalität
aussehen
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
laschet spricht von vielen kleinen
vorsichtigen schritten
bund und länder würden versuchen so viel
wie möglich gemeinsam zu entscheiden
am mittwoch berät die kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten
wie es mit den beschränkungen ab dem 19
april weitergeht und claus kleber
spricht nachher mit armin asche zu sehen
im heute journal um 10 vor 10
wegen der korona pandemie ist zurzeit
kaum etwas planbar eben
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen rät auch davon ab schon jetzt den
sommerurlaub zu buchen
für juli und august können niemand
verlässliche vorhersagen machen
der britische premier boris johnson hat
nach einer woche das krankenhaus wieder
verlassen per video dankte er den ärzten
und pflegern sie hätten sein leben
gerettet
auf anraten der ärzte soll der 55
jährige noch nicht arbeiten sondern sich
erst mal auf dem offiziellen ferien sitz
des premiers erholen
einen besonderen dank gab es auch für
das pflegepersonal in madrid eine
polizeikapelle spielte ein ständchen
hoffnung gibt den spaniern auch dies die
tendenz der neuansteckungen zeigt weiter
nach und nach russland
anfangs hatte die führung die gefahr
durch das virus kleingeredet
mittlerweile gilt auch hier bleibt zu
hause
die zahl der infizierten und toten
steigt und das gesundheitssystem gerät
mehr und mehr unter druck aus moskau für
begangen
eigentlich werden hier kriegsveteranen
behandelt doch am freitag wurde dieses
moskauer krankenhaus in ein zentrum für
cupid 19 patienten umgewandelt besucher
sind nicht erlaubt die hauptstädter
geben kleidung ab für ihre infizierten
verwandten und bekannten
mein freund wurde hier eingeliefert
nachdem er mit fieber in eine poliklinik
ging vor einer anderen moskauer klinik
warten gestern krankenwagen stundenlang
darauf auf das gelände fahren zu können
auch hier hat man sich auf kur wird 19
spezialisiert die zahl derer die mit
viren verdacht ins krankenhaus kommen
hat sich innerhalb von drei tagen
verdoppelt liegt derzeit bei 1300 fällen
täglich der bürgermeister war und ich
sage ihnen ganz deutlich das ist noch
nicht der gipfel
wir befinden uns er am fuß des berges
nicht einmal auf halbem weg zum gipfel
von anfang an gab es kritik an russlands
corona tests sie produzierten viele
falsche negative resultate gab nun
selbst das gesundheitsministerium zu je
katharina ist dann cupid 19 erkrankt die
journalistin hat das diagnose chaos
selbst erlebt ich habe die gleichen
symptome wie meine tochter aber wir
haben unterschiedliche nicht
nachzuvollziehende resultate erhalten
meine tochter wurde positiv getestet ich
zunächst negativ nach moskau darf nur
noch rein wer einen überzeugenden grund
oder das richtige nummernschild hat ab
morgen wird zudem mit qr-codes überprüft
ob die verordnete selbstisolation
eingehalten wird
die maßnahmen sind streng aber sie kamen
spät moskaus gesundheitssystem arbeite
bereits jetzt im notfall modus
offenbarte kreml sprecher peskow
in afrika sind die offiziell gemeldeten
corona fall seien noch vergleichsweise
niedrig das aber könnte sich schnell
ändern
die sogenannten maghreb staaten im
norden haben sich abgeschottet algerien
tunesien und marokko lassen fast
niemanden mehr einreisen
aber manche unsere zdf kollegen wohnen
vor ort und erleben hautnah wie schwer
der bbe kampf gegen das virus ist mit
anfälligen gesundheitssystemen und
ausgangssperren die viele arme menschen
hart treffen crystal hat
eine lebensmittellieferung im osten
algeriens gerät außer kontrolle
es ist eine handfeste rangelei um jeden
sack gries denn die ist ausverkauft
folge der korona maßnahmen
ich warne die regierung wenn ihr uns
kein essen bringt gehen wir alle auf die
straße und keiner hält uns auf die ärzte
sind schon auf der straße trotz
ausgangssperre
ihnen fehlt alles masken betten
medizingeräte bei den wenigen malen die
ich raus darf sich verzweiflung und
panik in den gesichtern der algerier
große ansturm auf die supermärkte die
lebensmittel werden knapp die
ausgangssperre wird oft nicht
eingehalten
die menschen sind auf sich gestellt
algerien steckt bereits in der
wirtschaftskrise
jetzt droht auch ein versorgungsnotstand
verzweiflung auch in tunesien
diese menschen ignorieren die
ausgangssperre und fordern die
versprochene finanzielle unterstützung
die nicht kommt die regierung setzt
jetzt auf diesen roboter um die korona
maßnahmen durchzusetzen
stoppt mum zeigen sie mir ihren ausweis
sie sollen mir den ausweis zeigen
tausende drängen sich vor den ämtern um
sozial hilfen zu erhalten sie brechen
die ausgangssperre in tunesien scheint
es wichtiger finanziell über die runden
zu kommen
als ich vor dem corona virus zu schützen
in marokko sind in manchen städten sogar
panzer fahrzeuge stationiert wer auf die
straße geht braucht eine genehmigung
es gibt jetzt eine masken pflicht für
alle marokkaner um die pandemie die hier
noch nicht stark ausgeprägt ist
einzudämmen
es wird dennoch eine herausforderung
denn die medizinische versorgung ist
eingeschränkt ein feldlazarett bei
casablanca soll nun die krankenhäuser
entlasten
ob das ausreicht weiß niemand wenn sie
sich über die entwicklungen online
informieren wollen dann empfehlen wir
ihnen unsere zdf heute app unter anderem
mit einem live blog zur corona krise
aber es gab auch noch andere nachrichten
heute
seit einem jahr gibt es ein neues label
in den supermarktketten ist zeigt wie
das tier gehalten wurde dessen fleisch
ich gerade kaufe verändert hat das
jedoch kaum etwas beim gekauften
rindfleisch
stammen 90 prozent beim schweinefleisch
fast 80 prozent nach wie vor aus
betrieben die nur die gesetzlichen
mindestanforderungen erfüllen
das zeigen zahlen die der deutschen
presse agentur vorliegen
etwas besser ist die situation bei
geflügel das kommt inzwischen vor allem
aus stellen mit mehr platz
einer der besten formel 1 fahrer ist tot
genauer gesagt der beste fahrer der nie
weltmeister wurde
sir stirling moss brite und alle die ihn
kannten sagen ein sehr sympathischer
hält 90 jahre wurde er viermal beendete
stirling moss eine saison als zweiter
und dreimal als dritter einmal hätte er
sogar gewonnen weil ein anderer fahrer
disqualifiziert wurde
aber er selbst legte protest gegen die
entscheidung ein und wurde erneut zweite
zitat ich würde das jederzeit wieder tun
weil es fair war ostern in diesem jahr
ganz anders so hat die sendung begonnen
und so endet sie auch mit einem
ungewöhnlichen konzert von andrea
bocelli
in diesem moment im mailänder dom ohne
publikum aber mit der klingenden
botschaft hoffnung ist stärker als das
virus hören sie mal
[Musik]
fehlt noch das wetter im norden bleibt
es überwiegend sonnig in der südhälfte
einige regenschauer 8 grad an der
nordsee und bis 20 grad am oberrhein
das war es von uns für heute danke sehr
für ihr interesse das gesamte team
wünscht ihnen frohe ostern und alles
gute wir sind auch morgen wieder da wenn
sie mögen und empfehlen jetzt die
dokumentation leeres jerusalem ostern zu
corona zeiten von unserer nahost
korrespondent in nicola albrecht auf
wiedersehen man sich gut